(ominous music)
- [All] Guess the Ex!
- I’m going to read a quote
from one of your exes.
If you think you know who that applies to,
ding that bell.
- I hope that my exes realize
how tan and happy I am now.
- I’m terrified of the result.
I think I was an okay guy,
I think I was an okay guy.
Was I okay?
- I’m pretty nervous to
play this game, because
the host said he had a tough
time tracking down my exes.
- I’m not nervous at all, cause I know
I was a good boyfriend.
So I’m not worried one bit.
(suspenseful music)
- “Our relationship
was like finally having
“the worrisome,
overprotective Jewish mother
“I never wanted.”
(bell dings)
- Shalom!
That’s me.
- [Host] I’m sorry Jesse,
that is not correct!
- What!
- Oh my god, wait! I’m dinging in.
Is it Jesse B?
- [Host] Nice work Gaby!
(bell ringing)
(everyone hollers)
- It was that Jesse?
- [Jesse B] It was me?
That was me.
The overprotective Jewish mother.
- “Being with this person
“was like standing in the shadow
“of a pharaoh.”
(bell dings)
- Uh, I think it’s Curly.
- [Host] You’d be correct!
(cheering)
- Come on, of course.
- “I fell in love with this person
“the first time
“they beat me up on the bus.”
(bell dings)
- [Gaby] Fuck.
- [Host] I think Curly
was in on the buzzer
early on that one.
(bell dings)
What’s your guess, Curly?
- I’d say Jesse K.
- [Host] You are correct!
- What?
- [Jesse K.] Wait a minute.
Why do you guys think I’m violent?
I’m a pacifist!
- Just the personal space issues you have
here alone, I can see trends leading to
a bus, and it being a bit abusive.
- “This person is fun, talented,
“smart, and great in the sack.
“And most of all they
loved my mechanic smell.”
(bell dings)
- I know that’s me.
I know that’s me cause I
know I’m good in the sack.
- I want that to be me.
- Curly, you nailed it.
(cheering)
- We’re all over here being so neurotic,
like, what is Curly’s life?
Like, Curly’s had the best life.
- Who are you?
- “This person will be totally loyal
“unless it conflicts with their interests
“at any given moment.”
(bells dinging)
- Is it Jesse K?
- Wait a minute, what?
I’m like the most generous person, ever.
I buy takeout for my,
well I don’t buy takeout
but I get the takeout.
- Well I don’t get the takeout,
but I enjoy the takeout.
- Who said it?
Was it me?
- Unfortunately Gaby you are incorrect!
(buzzer sounds)
(laughing)
(bell dings)
- Jesse B, no offense.
- That’s like dick first,
she just dinged several times
and louder!
(bells dinging)
- I’m sorry Jesse, you are incorrect.
- Thank God.
- What?
- [Gaby] Oh, god.
This is my nightmare.
- I’m going to read it one more time.
“This person will be totally loyal
“unless it conflicts with their interests
“at any given moment.”
(bell dings)
- I’m gonna say Gaby.
- [Host] You would be correct!
(yelling)
- I thought it was about me.
I thought it was about me!
- Okay, here’s the thing:
urly’s just had like, the best life
and everyone he’s dated loves him.
(bell ringing)
- So I would just like to say that
I contacted one of my ex-boyfriends
and asked him to be in this video,
and I was like “will
you be in this video?”
and he was like “I’m not over you,”
and like 22 seconds later we were having
hate sex in my apartment,
so thanks a lot Buzzed.
- I feel like that’s a good thing.
- Can you pay for my UTI medication?
- UTI medication for everyone!
(cheering)
- On...
- [All] Guess Your Ex!
- Guess The Ex.
(groans)
- We gotta do our arm thing.
- I’m hungry.
(soft music)